elles ont apporté le match de la
victoire les élans courtoise mélanie
guen et anaïs pointillart ont remporté
leur double le score de 7 0 ce succès
permet au volant d'elancourt d'accéder
aux barrages de maintien en division
honneur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur les huit rencontres face à l'équipe
2 de rueil malmaison et l'encours a
remporté six matchs les élans courtoise
honte oeuvré pour cette victoire seul
bémol les deux simple masculin
axel tu as dit nikola mon plongeon causé
des chacun une défaite
notre point fort c'est l'effet est dans
quasiment tous les clubs de daisy blinn
notre gros point fort c'est les filles
on a des filles très performante et
c'est grâce à elle il faudrait pas leur
dire mais c'est grâce à elle qu'on gagne
sur les doubles hommes et les simples
hommes on pèche un peu du manque un peu
ce petit quelque chose pour aller
chercher le money-time trouvant dans le
3ème set qui est pas en notre faveur sur
cette saison des difficultés sur cette
saison due aussi à des blessures
prochain rendez vous pour les volants
d'elancourt le week-end du 17 et 18 mars
pour les matches de barrage et peut-être
à la clé le maintien